the James Comey hearing and everything
that's going on with the Russia scandal
is obviously important it's news it must
be covered but we cannot let it distract
us from what is going on in our
republican-controlled House of
Representatives Thursday the same day as
the Comey hearing the House passed the
financial choice act this is a major
effort to destroy financial regulation
in the u.s. including much of what's
contained in the dodd-frank act or
dodd-frank act this hasn't yet passed
the Senate
it may not some of the things that
Republicans are doing in the house will
pass the Senate and very little
attention is being paid to it we've
talked about this pad because it is
scandal after scandal for Trump people
get distracted media gets distracted and
we just don't hear about the stuff that
Republicans are doing and we've got a
report on it and I think regardless
Republicans would be able to do it
anyway because they have the votes but
what they're able to get away with is
not face any political repercussions
that's because they don't have to do it
in front of the court of public opinion
no doubt about it and deal with the
constituent calls and deal with you
everything we're seeing in terms of net
neutrality and FCC complaints so this
bill would make major cuts to the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
that's a watchdog that is there to
prevent lending abuses remember the 2008
financial crisis was in great part
connected to bad lending practices this
bill that was passed in the House by
Republicans would diminish many of the
requirements set up by the dodd-frank
Wall Street Act as well as the Consumer
Protection Act it would get rid of the
Volcker Rule which inhibits banks
abilities to make hazardous wagers on
Wall Street using taxpayer money it
would do away with the fiduciary rule
which requires brokers to act in the
best interest of their retirement fund
customers this is a disaster and the
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan is
calling this bill the crown jewel of
Republicans mission to deregulate Wall
Street
I hope Pat that this doesn't pass the
Senate if it passes the Senate it will
probably have to have significant
concessions made but Republicans are
running rampant in the house right now
also dodd-frank was milk
was to begin with it was the one piece
of substantial regulation we were able
to get out of the Great Recession so for
that to be completely undermined I mean
that's rough and this is like when we
had 90% approval for universal
background checks after a massive mass
shooting in Sandy Hook which led to
countless deaths and you still couldn't
get it passed with President Obama in
the White House it is absolutely
pathetic Republicans love it Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell said
last month quote I'd love to do
something about dodd-frank particularly
with regard to community banks but that
would require Democratic involvement I'm
not optimistic this is why Democrats
need a platform like I implored last
week it's important to be anti Trump but
progressives need a platform I think
it's a good idea to focus on values
insofar as health care for everybody
focus on values and patriotism when it
comes to the environment and not
destroying the planet and really what I
mean by destroying the planet is
humanity right I mean the planet will
survive maybe less able to support human
life as we know it but you can't just
say we are the alternative to trump ISM
or we're opposed to what Trump is
especially if crumbs that Trump ends up
going away and the Republicans are
emboldened and are more able to do this
stuff so we really need people that
inspire us who we can rally around it's
not going to be Chuck Schumer it's
probably going to be someone more like
Bernie Sanders and what Elizabeth Warren
and Barack Obama were supposed to be
even though we've had questions recently
about some aspects of what's going on
with Elizabeth Warren you've got to pay
attention to what's going on in the
house because it is an absolute disaster
Pat and we hear so much about how
America is a center-right country that's
not the case when you go issue by issue
it's just a matter of messaging and if
Democrats are able to focus on a few key
issues like health care like the economy
yet they can win in 2018 and
legislatively this is a center-right
country partially because of
gerrymandering but not when it comes to
where people are on the issues